Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I am your host, Audrey Hamilton. In this episode, I talk with a psychologist about having those difficult but important end-of-life discussions with your loved ones. Psychology has a lot to add in terms of what we know about how people make decisions, manage their emotions, and handle relationships, all things that can affect how we approach these discussions. These are difficult things for people to bring up. They're not sure how to do it, but we know it's important for them to plan and to think ahead. So we want to give people a sense of confidence and competence that they know how to bring up these topics. Yes, I know. Talking about death sounds depressing.
你好，欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是一档由美国心理学会制作的播客。我是主持人奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。在本期节目中，我和一位心理学家探讨了如何与挚爱进行那些困难但却重要的临终讨论。心理学在帮助我们理解人们如何做决策、管理情绪以及处理人际关系方面有很多可以贡献的内容，所有这些都会影响我们如何看待这些讨论。对人们来说，提起这些事情很困难。他们不确定该怎么做，但我们知道，对他们来说提前规划和思考是很重要的。因此，我们希望赋予人们一种自信和能力，让他们知道如何提起这些话题。是的，我知道。谈论死亡听起来很压抑。
Yet, if done properly, it can actually lead to less stress as loved ones age and more benefits over time. Brian Carpenter is a clinical psychologist and professor of psychological and brain sciences at Washington University in St. Louis. His research focuses on family relationships in later life, particularly on communication and decision-making. He helps families face and address important end-of-life decisions, such as advanced directives and other health care-related decisions. Welcome, Dr. Carpenter. Thank you. It's great to be here. Nobody likes to talk about death, I mean, particularly with loved ones, especially when everyone is healthy and happy. But your research and clinical work have shown that it's best to deal with end-of-life issues.
然而，如果处理得当，随着亲人的老去，它实际上可以减少压力，并在长期内带来更多好处。布莱恩·卡彭特是圣路易斯华盛顿大学的临床心理学家以及心理与脑科学教授。他的研究重点是晚年家庭关系，特别是沟通和决策制定。他帮助家庭面对和解决重要的临终决策，例如预先指示和其他与医疗保健相关的决策。欢迎你，卡彭特博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。没有人喜欢谈论死亡，我是说，特别是和亲人谈论，尤其是当每个人都健康快乐的时候。但你的研究和临床工作表明，最好还是处理好临终问题。
as early as possible. You know, what should people be talking about with their families and why or loved ones? Well, you're right that nobody finds these topics particularly easy to talk about, but they are topics that everyone will need to face at some point in their life. And that's true for their family members and their close friends, but also true for themselves. So these are really universal issues that everybody needs to be thinking about. That doesn't mean that you need to be thinking about them every day all day long. but a little bit of advanced thinking and planning can really yield some benefits in the long term. So I like to suggest that people think about how they want their life to play out as they grow older. Now, again, I'll mention, though, that these are not just issues that are relevant only to older adults.
越早越好。你知道，人们应该和家人或亲人谈论什么？为什么？嗯，你说得对，没有人会觉得这些话题特别容易谈论，但这些是每个人在人生的某个阶段都需要面对的话题。对于他们的家人和亲密朋友来说是这样，对他们自己来说也是如此。所以这些真的是每个人都需要思考的普遍问题。这并不意味着你需要一整天、每天都在想这些事情，但稍微提前思考和规划确实能在长期带来一些好处。所以我喜欢建议人们思考随着自己年龄的增长，希望自己的人生如何演绎。现在，我再次强调，这些不仅仅是与老年人相关的问题。
People can die at any age, as you know, although most of the people who do die are older. But being ready for the end of your life is important no matter what age. you are, because it can happen to anybody at any time. So it's important for people to at least start thinking about what they would like their end of life to look like, how they want that to play out, what kinds of care they might like to have, what kinds of care they might not want to have at the end of their life, and how they want other important people in their life to be involved. How do they want them to be involved in terms of taking care of them, helping with their care, arranging for care, and how they might be helpful in making decisions
正如你所知，人们可能在任何年龄死亡，尽管大多数死者年龄较大。但无论你处于什么年龄，为生命的终结做好准备都很重要，因为它随时可能发生任何人身上。因此，对人们来说，至少开始思考他们希望自己的生命终点是什么样子的、他们希望人生如何演绎、他们希望在生命终点得到什么样的护理、他们可能不希望得到什么样的护理，以及他们希望生命中其他重要的人如何参与，这些都很重要。他们希望这些人如何参与照顾他们、协助护理、安排护理，以及他们如何在做决策时提供帮助
for people close to the end of their life when some people may not be able to make decisions for themselves. Can you give some examples of, let's say, someone that you've worked with or other families that you've worked with, and when you sit down with them and talk about these issues, what are kinds of questions they have for you? Sometimes people aren't even sure where to begin the conversation. what are the right topics for them to be talking about. So often we start very simply by talking about the things that are important for people to consider.
对于那些临近生命终点而有些人可能无法自己做决策的人来说。你能举一些例子吗，比如说，你合作过的人或其他合作过的家庭，当你坐下来和他们谈论这些问题时，他们对你有什么样的疑问？有时人们甚至不确定该从哪里开始对话，什么才是适合他们谈论的话题。所以我们通常从非常简单的事情开始，讨论人们需要考虑的重要事项。
And that includes thinking about where they want to live, what kinds of housing they might like to have towards the end of their life, where they might like to be if they have serious illness or might be approaching the end of their life. Would they prefer to be at home, in a hospital, some other residential setting, and there are benefits and drawbacks to all of those options? So housing is one thing that's important for people to think about. Medical care, obviously, is another one. What kinds of medical care do people want? And what kinds of medical care do people think they might not want as they become more sick? Another topic would be finances.
这包括思考他们想住在哪里，在生命接近终点时他们希望有什么样的住房，如果他们患有重病或可能接近生命终点，他们希望在哪里。他们是更愿意在家、在医院还是在其他居住环境中？所有这些选项都有利有弊。因此，住房是人们需要考虑的重要事情之一。显然，医疗护理是另一个。人们想要什么样的医疗护理？随着病情加重，人们认为自己可能不想要什么样的医疗护理？另一个话题是财务。
Family members and close friends you want to have involved in your life need to know what your financial situation is, where are important documents kept regarding your finance, And another topic has to do with the actual end of life itself. How do you want that to play out? And for some people, what do you want to have happen after you die? What kind of arrangements do you want to have? Who do you want to be there? Who do you want to be involved?
你想让其参与你生活的家庭成员和亲密朋友需要了解你的财务状况，重要的财务文件存在哪里。另一个话题与生命本身的实际终结有关。你希望这一切如何展开？对有些人来说，你希望在你死后发生什么？你希望做哪些安排？你希望谁在那里？你希望谁参与？
What might a service look like? So a little bit of planning, even though you're not going to be there, about how you want your life to be after you're gone. So all these things you're talking about, you can hit on a lot of hot, controversial buttons within your own family finances, family members, loved ones. How do you recommend bringing it up? I mean, do you bring this up at your holiday gathering or do you do it via email? I mean, is it particular to each situation, I imagine, but how do you recommend people go about it? You're right. Every family is going to be different. Every family has its own style,
追悼会可能会是什么样子？所以，做一点规划——尽管你不在场——关于你希望在你离去后生活是怎样的。所以你谈论的所有这些事情，都可能会触及你家庭内部许多敏感、有争议的雷区，比如财务、家庭成员、亲人。你建议如何提起这个话题？我的意思是，你是选择在节日聚会上提起，还是通过电子邮件？我想每种情况都有所不同，但你建议人们如何着手呢？你说得对。每个家庭都是不同的。每个家庭都有自己的风格，
its own personality, its own norms about how you talk about these kinds of sensitive topics. So everybody needs to think about their own individual family and what might work best for them. As a rule, I don't encourage people to have these kinds of conversations at important family events, like holidays or other kinds of gatherings. There's enough going on at Thanksgiving, for instance, that you don't really need to have a deep conversation about death and dying in the context of your Thanksgiving dinner. Some people think that that's logical to do it then because people are together in the same place. Let's break out my will and let's talk about it. Shove that pumpkin pie aside and let's talk about that. So, you know, I think that people should really think about these conversations as more of a process than an event.
有自己的个性，有关于如何谈论这类敏感话题的规范。因此，每个人都需要考虑自己的个别家庭以及什么对他们最有效。通常情况下，我不鼓励人们在感恩节或其他聚会等重要的家庭活动中进行这类对话。例如，感恩节期间有很多事情要做，你其实不需要在感恩节晚餐的背景下进行关于死亡和垂死的深入对话。有些人认为那时做合乎逻辑，因为大家都在同一个地方。让我们拿出我的遗嘱来谈谈吧。把南瓜派推到一边，我们来谈谈这个。所以，我认为人们应该真正把这些对话看作是一个过程，而不是一个事件。
It's not something that you should think about doing once and then it's over with, but these are conversations and issues that people should become comfortable talking about so that they can have maybe small conversations, break it down into bite-sized pieces, over a longer period of time. And why do you recommend that? One reason is that people's opinions and attitudes and beliefs might change over time. So if you have this kind of conversation at one point in your life, and then something meaningful happens to you or your loved ones, there's a divorce or change in your marital status or someone else in your family or someone you're close to has something serious
这不是那种你应该考虑做一次就结束的事情，而是人们应该习惯谈论的对话和问题，这样他们就可以在较长的一段时间内进行小规模的对话，将其分解成易于消化的部分。你为什么推荐这样做？原因之一是人们的意见、态度和信念可能会随着时间而改变。因此，如果你在人生的某个阶段进行了这种对话，然后你或你的亲人发生了有意义的事情——发生了离婚、婚姻状况发生变化，或者你家里的其他人或与你亲密的人发生了严重的事情——
happen to them, or some major story in the news happens, and you see how a person's end of life played out, that can change your opinions about how you want to be treated. So even if you've had the conversation, it's important to go back and revisit these issues when people experience important changes in their life. Now, you've been doing some research to try and develop tools for families,
发生在他们身上，或者新闻中发生了重大报道，你看到一个人的生命终点是如何演绎的，这可能会改变你对希望如何被对待的看法。因此，即使你已经进行过对话，当人们经历人生中的重要变化时，重新审视这些问题也很重要。现在，你一直在做一些研究，试图为家庭开发工具，
aiding them in these types of decisions and online tools. Can you talk about that research, what you found? Our goal, originally our goal was to try to figure out how we can help people know their preferences, know their family members' preferences for the things we've been talking about better. Because when you survey family members and ask them to predict how an older mother or older father would want to be taken care of, family members are notoriously bad at being able to predict those things with any accuracy. In fact, some of our research suggests that you might be just as accurate picking a person at random off the
帮助他们做出这些类型的决策以及在线工具。你能谈谈那项研究以及你发现了什么吗？我们的目标，最初我们的目标是试图找出如何帮助人们更好地了解他们的偏好，了解他们的家人对我们一直在讨论的事情的偏好。因为当你调查家庭成员并要求他们预测年迈的母亲或年迈的父亲希望如何被照顾时，家庭成员在能够准确预测这些事情方面出了名的糟糕。事实上，我们的一些研究表明，你随便在街上拉一个人，
street and asking them to guess what your mom or dad would want at the end of his or her life. So our first goal was to try to figure out, could we educate people and help them become more knowledgeable? And so that's one aim of this research. The second aim, though, and I think it's become a more important goal for me, is simply to get people who feel more comfortable talking about these things. As you said at the beginning, these are difficult things for people to bring up. They're not sure how to do it. But we know it's important for them to plan. and to think ahead. So we want to give people a sense of confidence and competence that they know how to bring up these topics and they can have a conversation and it can turn into some product or
让他们去猜你的爸爸或妈妈在生命终点时想要什么，其准确度可能也差不多。所以我们的第一个目标是试图弄清楚，我们能否教育人们并帮助他们变得更有见识？这就是本研究的一个目的。然而，第二个目标，我认为它对我来说已经成为一个更重要的目标，就是简单地让那些感觉更习惯谈论这些事情的人参与进来。正如你在开头所说，对人们来说，提起这些事情很困难。他们不确定该怎么做。但我们知道规划和提前思考对他们很重要。因此，我们希望赋予人们一种自信和能力，让他们知道如何提起这些话题，他们可以进行对话，并且这可以转化为某种产品或
output that's going to be helpful for them down the road. What about older adults who are struggling to even come to terms with aging or even death? Do you find it gets easier as they get older or more difficult? Everybody's different. So I think for some people, as they approach, the end of their life, there's some natural reflection about what their life has meant, a kind of attempt to make sense of what their life has been about. And with that can bring some trepidation, some worry that their life is coming to a close, maybe focus on some regrets that they might have, things they might have wished that they'd done differently, things that they might wish that they had said to people or not said to people, as the case may be. So for some people, I think,
对他们未来有所帮助的成果。对于那些甚至难以接受衰老或死亡的老年人，你怎么看？你发现随着他们年龄增长，这变得更容易了还是更困难了？每个人都是不同的。所以我认为对某些人来说，当他们临近生命终点时，会有一些关于他们的一生意味着什么的自然反思，这是一种试图理解他们的一生是关于什么的尝试。随之而来的可能会有一些不安，担心他们的生命即将结束，可能会关注他们可能存在的某些遗憾，比如希望自己当初能以不同方式做的事情，他们可能希望对别人说过或没有说过的话，视具体情况而定。所以对于有些人，我认为，
the approach at the end of life can be worrisome. For other people, not so much. They've found a way to live a life that's been satisfying to them. They realize that it's going to come to an end. It does for everyone. And if people can feel some sense of peace and understanding and kind of integration of their life, those people don't necessarily fear death or even talking about death. In fact, when I started doing some clinical work in this area, I was surprised at how receptive people were to talking about these things because they'd been wanting to talk about these issues, but nobody around them wanted to do it. So when you ask a person to talk about the end of their life, in my experience, many of them are anxious and welcome the opportunity to do so. It gives them an opportunity to express their feelings on it.
临终前的方法可能会让人担忧。对于其他人来说，并非如此。他们找到了过上令自己满意生活的方法。他们意识到这一切终将结束。每个人都是如此。如果人们能够感受到某种平静、理解以及对生命的某种整合，这些人就不一定会害怕死亡，甚至不害怕谈论死亡。事实上，当我开始在这个领域开展临床工作时，我惊讶于人们对谈论这些事情的接受度有多高，因为他们一直想谈论这些问题，但周围没有人愿意这样做。所以在我的经验中，当你要求一个人谈论他们的生命终点时，他们中的许多人会感到焦虑并欢迎这样的机会。这给他们提供了一个表达对此类感觉的机会。
I kind of am curious because you're a psychologist, a lot of the issues that you're talking about, advanced directives, medical care. I mean, those are the purview of an attorney, a physician who's working in gerontology or any other kind of profession like that. Why is talking about end-of-life issues, a psychological issue? Well, as you know, the end of life is an experience that doesn't unfold for any one particular health profession. that there, of course, are nurses and medical doctors involved in carrying somebody at the end of their life. There are also social workers, occupational therapists, spiritual and faith leaders, and psychologists who are important, have things to share at the end of life because the end of your life is a kind of culmination of physical and biological development, but also psychological and social development.
我有点好奇，因为你是一位心理学家，你谈论的很多问题，比如预先指示、医疗护理。我的意思是，这些都是律师、从事老年学工作的医生或任何其他此类职业的管辖范围。为什么谈论临终问题是一个心理学问题？嗯，如你所知，临终体验并非在某一个特定的健康专业中展开。当然有护士和医生参与照顾某人的临终生活。也有社会工作者、职业治疗师、精神和信仰领袖，以及心理学家，他们在生命终点时都很重要，有东西可以分享，因为你的生命的终点既是身体和生物学发展的高潮，也是心理和社会发展的高潮。
And psychology has a lot to add in terms of what we know about how, people make decisions, how they manage their emotions, what can lead to successful social relationships at the end of life, how we understand cultural diversity and how that plays out in important ways as a person is approaching the end of their life. So psychology really has lots of different things to add at this very, very important part of an individual's life. How do you deal with, and I know you do some clinical work, but when you're confronted with, let's say, someone who has a very different idea of how they think their loved one should
心理学在帮助我们理解人们如何做决策、如何管理情绪、是什么促成了生命终点时成功的人际关系、我们如何理解文化多样性以及当一个人接近生命终点时文化多样性如何以重要的方式发挥作用方面，有很多可以贡献的内容。因此，心理学在一个人的这个非常非常重要的生命阶段确实有很多不同的东西可以提供。你如何处理——我知道你做一些临床工作——当你遇到这样的人时，比方说，某人对他们的亲人应该如何
die versus how that own person thinks they should die. I mean, I imagine that's a difficult conversation to have. Nevertheless, how does it bore out usually? It can be very, very challenging for families, and I think the key there is that this needs to be conversations, is plural, you know, that you're not going to probably change somebody's mind by sitting down and talking to them for five or ten minutes about how things are playing out. that the goal is to try to help people understand where each other is coming from, you know, why they believe the things that they believe, and helping those individuals reach some sort of consensus and understanding
死亡有着非常不同的看法，而这个人自己认为他们应该如何死亡。我的意思是，我想这是一次艰难的对话。尽管如此，结果通常如何？这对于家庭来说可能非常非常具有挑战性，我认为关键在于这些需要是对话，是复数，你知道的，你可能无法通过坐下来和他们谈论五到十分钟事情是如何演绎的来改变某个人的想法。目标是试图帮助人们理解彼此的立场，你知道的，为什么他们相信他们所相信的事情，并帮助这些个体达成某种共识和理解
about what's going to be helpful for that group as a unit, that family as a unit or that care system as a unit, because people have different needs at the end of their life. And some patients want to be aware and sensitive of the people around them and how they're dying is affecting those people. And those care partners also want to try to respect what the person who is dying is going through as well. Well, Dr. Carpenter, thank you so much for joining us. It's been very interesting.
关于什么对那个群体作为一个整体、那个家庭作为一个整体或那个护理系统作为一个整体是有帮助的，因为人们在生命终点时有不同的需求。一些患者希望意识到并体贴周围的人以及他们的死亡如何影响那些人。那些护理伙伴也希望试着尊重垂死之人正在经历的事情。嗯，卡彭特博士，非常感谢你加入我们。这非常有趣。
You're welcome. Thanks for listening to our podcast. Make sure you check out our other episodes of Speaking of Psychology, and please subscribe if you haven't already. We are a proud member of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts. Please check out APA Journal's dialogue if you want to hear about the latest and most exciting psychology research. And if you're interested in the practice of psychology, you can listen to Progress Notes. Topics include how healthcare policy and social media affect practicing psychologists.
不客气。感谢收听我们的播客。请务必查看我们的《心理学说话》其他剧集，如果还没订阅，请订阅。我们是美国心理学会播客网络引以为豪的成员，其中包含其他精彩的播客。如果您想了解最新、最令人兴奋的心理学研究，请查看《美国心理学会期刊对话》。如果您对心理学实践感兴趣，可以收听《进展记录》。主题包括医疗保健政策和社交媒体如何影响执业心理学家。
You can find those podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speaking of psychology.org, to listen to even more episodes and gather more resources on the topics we discussed. Thanks for joining us. I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到这些播客。你也可以访问我们的网站 speaking of psychology.org，收听更多剧集并收集有关我们讨论主题的更多资源。感谢加入我们。我是美国心理学会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学说话》。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。